it's being seen as the most ambitious
proposal yet to restrict firearms in
canada prime minister justin trudeau
describes it as a national freeze of
handgun ownership
what this means is that it will no
longer be possible to buy
sell
transfer or import handguns
anywhere in canada
in other words
we're capping the market for handguns
under the bill canadians who already
have handguns can keep them but anyone
involved in domestic violence or
criminal harassment will lose their
firearm license the size of ammunition
magazines will be limited and there will
be increased penalties for gun smuggling
the crackdown comes days after the
school shooting in texas which killed 21
people while canada has stricter gun
laws in the u.s canadians have suffered
an increase of gun violence in recent
years
in 2020 it banned semi-automatic rifles
after 22 people were killed in a mass
shooting in nova scotia
some gun owners say they're contesting
that ban in court
the new legislation is expected to be
enacted in the autumn but a rush to buy
handguns ahead of the ban isn't expected
authorities say sales are already
heavily regulated
katya lopez
al jazeera